monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires étrangères Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur mes chers collègues
le passé rejoint aujourd'hui le présent
oui le passé rejoint aujourd'hui le
présent car nous étudions une
proposition de résolution
transpartisanes à l'initiative de ma
collègue Anne gente sur la
reconnaissance de Lolo de mort comme
génocide qui éclaire si tristement ce
que vivent depuis le 24 février dernier
nos amis ukrainiens et c'est aussi face
aux atrocités du présent que l'on prend
conscience de l'importance de ce
confronter et de reconnaître l'effet du
passé
Lolo de mort littéralement
l'extermination par la fin qui a frappé
l'Ukraine il y a 90 ans et l'histoire
méconnue d'une tragédie orchestrée par
le régime totalitaire soviétique ce
crime de masse a délibérément ciblé les
paysans ukrainiens et à travers eux
l'ensemble de la nation ukrainienne dans
la volonté de l'anéantir
Lolo de mort est longtemps demeurer tu
dissimulé par le pouvoir stalinien mais
également par les populations victimes
durablement traumatisées il a également
fait l'objet d'arbitrage géopolitique
d'aucun privilégiant la construction
d'une paie inachevée aux dépens de la
reconnaissance des crimes passés cette
famille organisée par le totalitarisme
stalinien pourrait avoir causé plusieurs
millions de morts en Ukraine jusqu'à 10
millions si l'on tient compte des
victimes hors du territoire ukrainien
notamment au Kazakhstan des millions de
victimes morts de fin résultat de
l'échec de la politique de
collectivisation forcée lancée par
Staline au début des années 30 pour
moderniser l'URSS les résultats
également de mesures délibérées visant à
affamés le peuple ukrainien
le régime soviétique a ainsi prélevé
dans le Grenouillet à blé de l'Europe
d'énormes quantités de grains et face à
la résistance des Ukrainiens Staline et
son entourage ont décidé d'accentuer la
répression interdisant l'exode des
familles ukrainiennes qui tentaient de
fuir vers les villes pour trouver de
quoi se nourrir alors que Vladimir
Poutine n'hésite jamais instrumentaliser
l'histoire pour justifier sa guerre et
renforcer son pouvoir la reconnaissance
et la condamnation de mort en tant que
génocide revêtent une importance toute
particulière sans instrumentaliser avec
toutes les arrières pensées possibles le
droit international
si la réalité de la famine est reconnue
désormais la question de sa
qualification peut demeurer pas pour
nous qui assumons de parler de génocides
dans la lignée des historiens comme
Andrea graciosi Barbara Martin Nicolas
verte ou romane serbine bien sûr tous
les génocides ne sont pas identiques
mais ils ont bien des caractéristiques
communes ou trop les faits des millions
de morts par la famille
l'intentionalité des actions menées par
Moscou suffisamment et indiscutablement
documenté des montres le caractère
génocidaire de la grande famine
ces actions savamment orchestrées
constituent une volonté délibérée du
pouvoir soviétique de punir et
d'exterminer la nation ukrainienne en
tant qu'ensemble politique parce que son
opposition à sa politique menaçait
l'unité et l'existence de l'URSS
Rafael Lemkin l'inventeur du terme
génocide comme la rappeler annegène tech
parler de trois génocides le génocide
arménien la Shoah et le lot d'aua il
considère que l'intention de Staline
était bien l'anéantissement de la nation
ukrainienne à travers d'abord la
destruction de linkedincia ukrainienne
de l'église puis des paysans à travers
la famille organisée
comme le Parlement européen est presque
30 parlements nationaux avant nous
j'aurais aimé que notre assemblée
reconnaisse et condamne unanimement
cette tragique de l'histoire pour ce
qu'elle est un génocide car ce devoir
nous incombe pour honorer la mémoire des
victimes de ce crime de masse
cette reconnaissance doit s'accompagner
également du ouverture des archives les
historiens doivent pouvoir continuer
documenter les faits pour que le lot de
bord ne soit plus un angle mort de
l'histoire
le moment où intervient l'examen de
cette proposition de résolution n'est
évidemment pas anodin et nous l'assumons
dans le contexte de la guerre en Ukraine
reconnaître et condamner le génocide de
Lolo de mort constitue un soutien au
peuple ukrainien dont la reconnaissance
des crimes de masse perpétré à son
endroit par le régime soviétique mais
c'est aussi un puissant message
politique que nous envoyons à l'Ukraine
pour la soutenir dans sa résistance face
à l'agresseur russe pour toutes ces
raisons le groupe démocrate votera en
faveur de cette résolution je vous
remercie
merci